nous sommes un pays qui soigne bien qui
ne prévient pas assez et donc votre
question me permet d'abord d'insister
sur un sujet qu'on n pas assez évoqué
même si on parle de santé je m'en
réjouis depuis tout à l'heure c'est que
dans la stratégie de santé que la
ministre aura à conduire auprès du
Premier ministre et qu'elle connaît bien
parce que elle l' porté aussi dans sa
ville dans son agglomération et puis
dans ses compétences antérieures on doit
beaucoup mieux prévenir aujourd'hui on
va développer les diagnostics de santé
pour les enfants les adolescents et les
adultes on a massivement
développé la vaccination et on va
continuer par exemple pour le le papiom
virus et d'autres et donc on doit
beaucoup mieux
prévenir ce qui veut dire aussi qu'on
doit conjurer une forme de fatalité
français qui est qu'on consomme trop de
médcine en même temps qu'on a une des
médecines les plus socialisées du monde
c'est-à-dire où c'est pas le
consommateur qui la paye mais c'est
toujours pareil il y a pas d'argent
magique quand c'est pas le consommateur
qui la paye c'est le contribuable qui la
paye et donc au moment où de manière
sérieuse je vois ce que nos compatriotes
peuvent dépenser pour les forfaits de
téléphonie la vie quotidienne se dire
qu'on va passer de 50 centimes à 1 €
pour un paquet de pour un paquet pardon
pour un
médicament boîte de médicament j'ai pas
le sentiment qu'on fait un crime
terrible je pense que ça responsabilise
c'est une bonne mesure il faut
responsabiliser sur la consommation par
contre ce qu'il faut garder c'est un
élément de justice c'est pour nos
compatriotes qui ont des affections de
longue durée c'estàdire des maladies qui
supposent des prescriptions régulières
eux faut continuer de les protéger et eu
ils sont protégés parce qu'on a mis un
plafond c'est qu'ils sont pas plus de 50
€ par an ça faut le garder donc on va
faire quelque chose de juste je crois
c'est-à-dire qu'on responsabilise la
médecine le soin les médicaments ça ne
coûte pas rien on prend déjà beaucoup en
charge quasiment tout et donc oui moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose de
passer de 50 1 € par boîte de médicament
franchement ça ne me choque pas quand je
vois ce que coûte beaucoup d'autres
éléments de la vie quotidienne qui sont
moins essentiells que le médicament
quand il est prescrit ou quand il est
important et à côté de ça on va
continuer de protéger ceux qui ont un
besoin de consommation régulière parce
qu'ils ont des affections de longue
durée et ils continueront à avoir cette
protection parce qu'ils auront un
plafond de 50 € par an pour ce reste à
charge parce qu'il faut
responsabiliser c'est une bonne
chose